tweetie bonsoir les mecs alors comme
d'hab quand je l'entends stream
je dirais qu ici s'il marche tout
bêtement c'est quand même un peu la base
quand tu stream 7 à voir si ça marche
donc s'il ya quelqu'un dans le chat qui
peut me le dire direct tant mieux sinon
on va on va juste jeter un oeil
et puis et puis on va se lancer pour ce
petit stream alors j'ai envie de jouer
les gants vie contre vous en faites pas
ce que l on a fait un petit test sur les
arénas pour
pour jouer des gangs y est ça s'est pas
très bien passé et donc bah je compte
sur vous déjà pour jouer des gambie
contre vous si vous êtes là parce que
pour moi je suis pas sur une chaise
comme tv alors bon je vais regarder je
regardais le programme court en est le
programme annoncé nous c'est nous qui
arrivons et est donc et donc j'ai
vraiment envie de de tester sa de tester
ça de trouver des nouveaux gambie et
d'avoir un peu éventuellement vos gambie
aussi s'il ya du monde ce qu'on n'est
pas on n'est pas très nombreux pour le
moment pas sinon je tenterai des propres
gambie je chercherai des idées quoi mais
met donc mais donc voila et puisque ce
soir ya le foot avec la belgique et tout
ça donc en plus en sachant que que nos
amis belges bas sont francophones
on a probablement des gens des gens qui
regardent et on commence contre kral en
gambie avec les blancs bon je vais faire
un devis avec des cartes sur des quatre
cavaliers apsys c'est ce que je suis en
train de chercher donc il va tenter le
black mardi meurent même si j'aime pas
trop même si j'aime pas trop et on va
voir ce que ça peut donner un look est
donc là je sais pas j'ai entendu parler
de ce coup mais ce que c'est dans cette
position exacte ou pas à voir donc on va
développer pour le moment un donc les
call you do oeste de pas ne pas prendre
le matos directes de continuer un peu
comme ça et maintenant de prendre 5
puisqu'on a réussi à protéger notre dame
vous ça va faire que quand il prend on
va prendre et sur cavaliers ici est ce
que j'ai quelque chose à faire
celle qui menace le fou
et qui menacent le pion donc les
attaques deux choses à la fois ce qui
n'est jamais très sympa j'avais je
refusais accueilli des sacs même cavalli
est fou et c'est complètement débile
surtout fkt affaires kelly sait si ce
jeu pour aller pour du sii souffrance et
7 mais j'y crois pas et je vois un truc
de type tour des quatre cas il prend
trois pions prend 2,3 à l'esc on va
tenter comme on est dans l'esprit de
façon d'aider gambie ddd des machins des
trucs comme ça aujourd'hui à main j'ai
fermé le chat gfa mais le châssis à
quelqu'un qui écrit vous allez voir ce
qu'on va faire on va prendre
il va faire fou c'est simple on va faire
qu'il prend 2,4 ha mince il le fait pas
ok j'ai réouvert le chat donc on est de
nouveau là alors hein comment faire
ouais je suis complètement ratée avec
second bien
bon bah on va faire ça en fait
complètement de la merde là pour le
moment c'est une très mauvaise partie
ce break marne y meurent là alors sur
peut-être peut-être qu'elle et ses 3,5 à
l'air d'être fort je les comprends même
pas ma qualité que c'est insupportable
les laïcs sont insupportables sur eux ni
matériel ils prennent pas
il va vraiment pas prendre en fait
le mac n'est pas du tout intéressé par
mon matériel quoi qu'en ait clairement
et concrètement le mec s'en fout total
ça j'ai jamais vu encore le mec qui
refuse de prendre la qualité c'est mal
et il a peut-être raison d'un point de
vue pratique est quand même quoi tu peux
prendre le matos tu as le droit quand
même de prendre le matos tu peux le
faire quoi bon mais il faut lui faire
payer du coup on n'a jamais vu encore
c'était nouveau comme quoi aux échecs
on peut toujours se faire surprendre
c'est ce qui fait la magie de ce jeu
revenir là pour le mans je suis pas une
partie brillante mais bon on va passer
là haut a peut-être du fou prend assise
c'est un moment qui sait il va y avoir
du fou prend 1,6 ça va pas être folichon
folichon mais ses pions plus c'est quand
même très étrange comme parti je passais
une bonne idée d'aller changer mais
maintenant c'est fait on se retrouve
avec un petit pion plus qu'on essayait
d'aller faire fructifier
on a des petits problèmes d' espaces et
on a des problèmes de pendule on va
essayer créer un pion passé a acquis des
deux on va colmater
si on passait à ça peut pas faire de mal
ça va éloigner le roi et ça nous
permettent d'aller jouer de ce côté là
avec quatre échecs on va un petit peu
échangé à ces matchs joué ça très mal
joué en crise de temps j'ai un peu fait
de la merde mais je crois qu'ils
haïssent et quatre sapeurs prisé à 5
mais ça c'est bien joué de sa part
on va prendre d'ici à l'école est un
échec
on va coller un autre échec on allait
prendre le pion on vient avec le cavale
allez on va revenir par là le cahier
bien placé ce qui protège ça on va se
barrer de ce côté là
et ça ça gagne tout seul bon là ça a été
puni ça a vraiment été puni pour part
pris la qualité il a été puni pour avoir
pris la qualité en face que du coup il
s'est à la sur cinq du cookie c3 est ce
que c est complètement de la merde
vingt cinq c'était pas mal joué et y
avait lieu de fou b4
je pensais que c'était malin ce que je
faisais mais c'est un peu pourri
on verra que je regarde il faut qu'on se
renseigne on va faire une autre partie
on va faire une autre partie
on joue contre jabès faire un genre qui
inquiète au même par un jour on va faire
un pion qui tour aller des cinq un peu
comme dans une greenfield match aller on
sait s'ils sont à jouer qui a et b 6e 5
faut pas pousser de façon voilée changé
il va se laisser glisser tout est changé
[Musique]
je trouve ce que j'allais faire cavaler
f3 plus tôt on va empêcher ou g5 ce pas
idiot quand ils jouent pas sûr de
détenir va faire h5 vois vraiment pas
peut-être servir un petit fou g4
abandonner si je provoque f3 je serai
pas mécontent je vais aller coller la
dame avant h4 parce qu'elle est vraiment
bien placé j'en sais rien mais moi ne se
fait pas attaquer ici à mettre la
fenêtre ou pas j'aime pas du tout la
manière dont je joue je trouve que c'est
assez mauvais foucher cas tu vas faire
f3 il va revient avec le four en f2 on
voit qu'il avait classé un petit mur
face à montrouge et 7 et
on est carrément mal un far west
allons à faire ou à vii
au cas où on ferait un truc avec f6 aux
armes mf5 c'est très moche à f/5 donc il
fait froid quand même au caire pour lui
il ya foule prend f7 qui est chiant
fouet si c'est évidemment j'ai pas envie
f5 j'ai pas envie du tout puisqu'il faut
f2 j'ai envie de rien la foux 17 je peux
pas vous prend b6 c'est une grosse
position de merde hein
est-ce qu'on tente le fait qu'on a un
plus gros lots et qu'on propose nul
parce que ça peut fonctionner à
commencer par la mousse est ce qu'on
tente là propos de nul a laissé une
manière d'arnaqué proposé nul mais qui
refusent ils menacent fou ici
elle va couvrir
les menaces de venir en g5 avec
lecavalier dans mais c'est horrible on
va faire ça lors du fou des savants se
fait vraiment massacre et là c'est un
massacre
heureusement que la partie compte pour
rien c'est de faire fuir les lieux cinq
de survivre un peu qu'est ce que ça pas
la meilleure chance d'aller pour cette
finale
c'est une très mauvaise finale
évidemment mais parfois c'est mieux de
switcher pour la finale fut impressionné
vraiment mauvaise
c'est peut être plus facile de tenir en
finale parce que j'aurai au cas où au
moins on s'active un peu on a donné un
pion mais mais on a obtenu un peu
d'activité on a on a stoppé le problème
sur ce pion mais on reste très mal alors
protéger un peu comme on peut
si sam effrayer complètement
je sais de colmater comme je peux 1 7
tours de 8 qui a valu aux 6 pouces et 6
y aura tours france et 7 mai au quai il
l'a pas vu on va faire pousser 6
maintenant on chasse un peu m la tour en
huit on va échanger ça on est mal autant
aussi un faux et figurants pêche la
poussée du pion qui on va prendre une
fois on va mettre le feu en dessin qu'on
menace prisé prises ici
alors est ce qu'elle est nulle cette
finale c'est possible c'est possible
qu'elle soit nul ça te fous de couleurs
opposées
ou pas
mais le truc c'est que j'ai pas assez de
temps pour faire un nul
quand bien même ça aurait été nulle
j'avais pas assez de temps ok ok bien vu
de la part de notre adversaire on va
chercher un autre refusé la revanche
quand bien même elles vmz sais pas quel
genre de gambie on peut jouer contre ces
trucs là voilà ce truc là que la jouer
genre dessin qui prennent du fait ces
six là il prend même pas les mecs
prennent pas mes gants bigre les mecs
sont pas dans l'esprit
les mecs ne sont pas dans l'esprit
gambie ce soir du coup avec le fou g7
c'est cool parce qu'on empêche un peu de
pousser leur vessie theater du fou prend
et cavaliers des quatre où cavaliers t4
direct d'ailleurs si fais rien je
pensais à rock vous prend vous prend
caïds et 4 et d'aller prendre en f3 et
abîmer la structure est sûre quel est
des deux chu riquet id4 peut-être direct
foot rend à faire cavalier g4 comme ça
on va attaquer ici peut-être laissé le
fou en prison peut-être pas idiot genre
faire rock laissez-le fois en prise
après poussé au centre je vais peut-être
fait ça perso quand il est bon ben j'ai
envie d'aller mettre le cavalier en d4
s'y prend on prendra g2 et s'y prend ses
sept
on a l'embarras du choix
mais j'ai envie juste de reculer le flou
on va garder les pièces sur l'échiquier
alors là l'embarras du choix
bon on va suivre les conseils de mur tu
as on va prendre faire qu'il prend à
quelques proches devant j'ai trouvé les
cavaliers des deux qui m'empêche de
sortir une affaire qui est des cinq ce
que je voyais pas en fait comme empêché
de sortir lecavalier après cavaliers age
ii d'amd 5
et comme je voyais pas je voulais le
jouet conseil de mur tu as donc
forcément un bon conseil
landais une très bonne position arrive à
devoir jouer grand roque mais il va se
prendre une marée de pions sa structure
de plus est complètement cassé là il
s'est quand même fait bien dominé par
par notre gang guillot final 1 j'ai très
envie de jouer un truc simple comme a6b
ces cinq jeux pas et c'est optimale
optimale
mais mais ça fait plaise je vais mettre
le pied si je pencherais plutôt mille
cavaliers a eu 4 à sa place l'atout
enfin je trouvais que camaïeu casse
c'est pas mal joué pour essayer de
bloquer là je fais réussissent histoire
de bien glinglin démons pions et de
voilà et ça me rappelle une partie d'al
équine d'ailleurs et la dame des six
tours des huit tours 17 retour des 8 on
va les fixes et la faiblesse on va
préparer du v4 à tout moment vous aurez
joué sur la faiblesse en d3 et sur le
roi faible je vois qui peut il se permet
du cavalier à 4 mai à la rythmique est à
4 je m'en fout quoi je bouge madame en
d6 par exemple est plus ou moins obligé
de revenir en c3 du coup je vais faire
du retour 17 tours des huit on va
convenir vraiment très fortement vie
c'est ça il ya du c4 qui arrive à tout
moment mais voilà il arrive maintenant
il aurait pu être due aux coûts
précédent et du coup on va on va s'en
prendre directement à détroit donc
détroit et gagner des trois tombes des
deux mains en est on va voir du dam des
trois échecs tout en souplesse
on va juste prendre ici comme des trois
échecs c'est souple au qui ont la
batture en souplesse mais qui peut pas
rejouer donc ça ça veut pas vraiment
rejouer ce soir quand on gagne ah mais
ça rejoue par la force des choses allons
intenter gambie débile il a pris les
pions
on va voir comment il va se débrouiller
maintenant
alors avancé on est tenté l'étude du fou
les cinq échecs ça n'a pas l'air de trop
fonctionné mais bon
ça fonctionne pas du tout donc nouveaux
sacrifices complètement pourri ok tu
qu'on va jouer avec rock tour un tour
prend 1,5 à essaie de mettre la pression
sur 7 sur a6 françois caillé prend 17 et
il n'a pas le vraiment le temps de
prendre b5 donc qui couvrent pour les
mecs on est là pour s'amuser ou pas
c'est quand même complètement de la
merde à ce que je veux faire
je pensais à cavalier prend lorsque vous
l'avez compris on apprend et d'un f3
mais bon y'a tellement rien c'est
tellement le désert bon tout ça ça
fonctionne pas alors qu'est ce qui peut
fonctionner
j'aime est la tour en un plan b 1 pour
commencer ça mange pas de pain ça mettra
toujours ça sous pression et ça m'enlève
de la donc ça me fait quand même deux
trucs
bon allez je pense qu'il faut y aller
maintenant c'est très mauvais mais bon
on n'a pas le choix
pas le choix vous est fou prend cavalier
reste est peut-être possible mais je
pense qu'il a repris du cavalier finale
pense pas que ça a donné grand chose
l'histoire d'un mec 3 je vais essayer de
ramener ça tant bien que mal par là bas
parce que si jamais le calibrage c'est
tiamat bon
alors qu'à et des cinq dames prend
cavaliers province est je pense pas que
ça mène à grand chose je vais cacher le
fou là bas je vais essayer de peut-être
avoir envie de faire ça maintenant je
suis quand même tapis dans l'ombre avec
mes deux fous j'suis tapis dans l'ombre
j'aime bien tapie enfin je t'aime bien
tapi dans l'ombre
bon
je vais jouer ça qui est pas le plus
fort mais parce que j'ai envie de tenter
le cavalier g5 à amira paquet prompt à
vii mat
ar je voulais tenter le beau jeu mais ça
n'a pas fonctionné
bon je repassais par la sage à les
menacer de ce côté là
cette dame b5 ici donc et on va prendre
il va apprendre à prendre et je pense
qu'on reprend 1,4 à la fin et qu'on va
rester avec un pion n'en a pas de pions
plus mais
mais on va l'amener à saint patoche s'y
prend pas ce qu'on veut nassr à tour f4
ok il prend pas bon je vais je vais
aller ici
on a plus énormément de temps à prendre
là j'aurais dû faire ça direct et
carballo 6 tc sète si j'avais vu si
seulement j'avais vu ça direct on n'en
serait pas là pour aller choper ça
ce qu'on peut aller prendre un set
on va essayer de lui choper double
attaque et tour à deux et on colmate bon
il est peut-être beaucoup plus rapide
que le vrai jeu perdue comme un conte
ses pions
il est très rapide
ok très rapide mais
mais pas assez pour nous à il a été
rapide mais il a oublié le petit tour
pranger 3 assez cool c'est cool c'est
cool ça fait plaise
très rapide mais très nul nous dit
qu'ils nous disent à grand cheikh après
j'espère qu'un jour tu seras aussi
rapide et aussi nul que lui mais mais ça
alors ressortissants russes ont réussit
vraiment pas à faire de combien il a
suffi que je mette contente d gambie
pour qu'on n'y arrive pas on tente un
truc bizarre
j'aime pas trop jouer avec le calice et
six dans les ouvertures à d4 d5 je
trouve assez mal placé souvent mais bon
alors stc changé on n'a pas trop le
choix de façon ce que je joue pour eux
cinq fois et sûrement en france on prend
feu 5 on essaye de deux blocs et lui
derrière le pion
chacune qui plaisant non mais on a
compris que tu plaisantes et savait
qu'il était assez nul après mes seins
mais bon il était très rapide tout en
étant nul il était rapide donc sur des
cinq affaires qui est but on va revenir
on va faire ça et on va revenir comme ça
fait si fede 5 c'est cool c'est qu'après
peut-être un jour à même du cavalier g4
dans le bon dans le bon tempo
je vais me concentrer sur le centre je
pense pas que ma tour en h soit très
utile je vois pas vraiment comment je
n'utilise donc on va se concentrer là tu
as pris ce qui me fait peur c'est des 5
et 8 c 4 des cas tu vas tout envoyé par
genre à 3 bkt tout ça quand je m
je suis un peu compris mais là
j'aime pas ma pause
que je compte le centre nc qui va se
fiancer 3 qui est très bien placé
voilà on va faire fonctionner un peu de
tactique j'ai pas si ça marche mais
l'idée secure dame française en haye
adam d'amis si j'avais pas vu j'avais
pas vu est trop fort la guerre ça là il
a vraiment très bien joué c'est
complètement abandonna bhl qui nous a
très bien joué cette tactique marché
paphos était sûr que ça fonctionnait pas
bien joué et provoque les changes des
dames
il prend f7 et là c'est la cata total il
m'a bien dominer un hymne à il m'a bien
battu dans ce district a caressé si ceux
ci qui va en mauve et noir
il faut dire qu'il attaque vraiment bien
quoi trop fort ouais c'est de le rejouer
dur de jouer les ouvertures bizarre mais
c'est bien fait de mina l'on va retenter
truc avec g4 mais j'ai par contre cet
adversaire fut un peu sont marrants la
photo
alors
encore une ouverture un peu mais ce truc
avec j'éclate franchement a déjà essayé
hier tu prends veut 5 après white
systématiquement c'est vraiment très
mauvais en fait tu te fais trop de trous
quoi
je te fais trop de trous j'aime pas du
tout ce truc là j'ai fait hier j'ai aimé
aucune position soit faire un petit peu
regardé avec l'ordi ce qu'il est
faisable mais sinon j'ai l'impression
que tu es juste mal direct sans raison
en est l'occasion des 5
c'est vraiment pour tenter un piège quoi
ses rangs pour dire je les tente et quoi
je prends une fois un instrument qui
freine la dame est bon fac et prend ses
sets mais bon c'est vraiment des pièges
à la con depuis tout à l'heure on va
chasser de son va se faire tacticien
moment donné ceinture est ce que je
tentais séquelles et ses quatre pour
dévier fou pranger celle qui est prend
des deux marche pas on va prendre une
fois faire f 4l a surclassé 4 dames c3
on a enfermé le cavalier les tontons je
crois qu'on est enfermé le cavalier je
crois qu'on a enfermé le cavalier parce
que kelis et qu'adam c3 et y'a pas
d'autres cases tiré par les cheveux
sains
c'est tiré par les cheveux mais ça
fonctionne on va prendre du coup on va
faire dame c3 on va lui mettre le
clouage on va préparer cavaliers f3
infertiles f3 quand même on va échanger
ouais ok bon enfin kg 5 maintenant jouer
sur ce clou âge là toujours sympa tosh
et surtout réfute cavaliers ou six pour
n'étais pas là pour rigoler dans cette
partie 1
on n'était pas là pour rigoler 1 on va
leur jouer alors à lui tenté le second
dit mais on n'était pas là pour s'amuser
là on était là pour sanctionner alors
allé se venger sur ce pion
d'affaires qui a aidé 5 cette chance
cette super chiant bon on faire
autrement alors
à ces super changer des mauvaises
positions comme ça dansait gambie ça va
vraiment pas et gambit autant ça va
aider gambie saab tu peux pas tout le
temps je vais des gambier
malheureusement aux échecs c'est chiant
voilà attend et ce qui me donne du répit
mais si je peux faire c'est 6 tu vois un
choix heureux quand même que kelly c3 du
coup je prends là bas et il peut me
faire tilt pros de ces intermédiaires
prises et cahiers la relève
ces objets de prende et ma finale est
complètement pourri mais bon je sais me
survit au mans
non je comprends pas pourquoi on n'est
pas sûr chase tv
je prends bruit m'a pris comme ça parce
qu'on fait là du coup il me permet quand
même de le doubler des pions je suis pas
sûr que je veuille prendre ce qui
reprend et du coup il y aura du fou des
six
je vais faire f 5 ils peuvent vi avait
que 5 mais il peut faire ça aussi
et du coup je vais pouvoir lui faire du
d5 je suis très heureux s'il me fait m6
est prise je pense qu'ils ont progressé
5 c'était grosse erreur stratégique
à moins qu'il ya un truc là puissant
mais sinon n'a pas perdu ta bonne humeur
meurs meurs meurs meurs tu as pas perdu
ta bonne humeur murder meurs meurs comme
takita un mec qui écrit dans le chat
alors c'est quoi son taux j'arrive pas a
lire ces nanas deux fils qui salue kevin
cela fait un petit moment que je regarde
les vidéos youtube et que je suis abonné
en plaisir de tout voir en live j'espère
voir passer la soirée en ta compagnie et
qui écrit très bon travail dans merci
tonton élan puissant va lui faire des
saints dont il joue vraiment très malin
stratégiquement c'est quand même le
niveau zéro se fait complètement dominé
à partir d'une opposition va dominer je
pense que je suis mieux un an
je reconnais qu'il arrive cinq décrira
que je vais prendre ans d'écart en c3 il
provoque donc je prends j'en étais à f/5
il va faire foulage toi tu fais la colle
un petit coup de hache 5 avoir fait fou
pro f 5 je reprends avec un petit h 5 en
force à hk tu faire fou 17
ok ça j'ai pas pensé c'est pas idiot je
fais partie des sept quand même
cette phase là de la partie se passe
super bien joué mais mais ça devrait
suffire
le plan b si ce jeu avec des 4 ouais
j'ai pas super bien joué cette phase
honnêtement j'ai pigé pas de quoi frimer
mais ça suffit
voilà je comprends pas trop il a roissy
un encore pourquoi s'être emballé mais
bon il est tellement mal autant
il était tellement mal autant que de
toute façon j'ai envie de dire ça pasqua
a misé clic à bail mais bon on n'y peut
rien et on va le reprendre
on va lui refaire la même allure faire
le g4 qu'on va essayer d'emploi
réfléchir à comment elle s'y prend pas
le pion sans l'a déjà vu dans les
parties précédentes quand le pion n'ai
pas mangé
du coup on va protéger à fond
mais quand le pion survie on est très
heureux
alors qu'est-ce qui me veut enfin ces 5
et coûteux
si fef si je tentais dam des trois ans
dans l'esprit que sinon on va jouer
juste trois mètres le fou ici
ok mesdames détroit quand même l'esprit
au dessus de tout il prend pas la pièce
il a bien raison à mon avis ont reculé
avec le fourrage 3 qui va prendre
prendre warocqué évoquait déjà récupéré
à chier quoi bon n'ont encore pas une
très bonne partie de ma part ça devrait
suffire quand même aller l'esprit à fond
qu'avait lieu 5 les pièces c'est de la
merde
voilà ce qu'est un peu trop d'esprits
mais bon allez on y va on y croit on y
croit on envoie des pièces en un assez
cool
on est quand même un peu short ans mais
bon
on est très short mais bon ça lui permet
de développer le cavalier peut-être 1
je pense pas qu'on arrive à conclure là
c'est quand même par de très loin mais
on en voit c'est génial d'envoyer autant
qu'à envoyer des pièces tout le temps
partout et on a absolument jamais rien à
[ __ ] tu es là que pour envoyer
à prendre une fois
on peut prendre l'un faire échec et
prendre là mais je passe c'est très bon
on peut commencer par dame b 4-1 mais a
poussé 6
ouais mais peut-être dame b 4 pouces et
six prises prise tour d un cavalier 17,6
m haies et sur dame 8 peut-être on peut
on peut faire des petites
carabistouilles il ya ça qui est non
protégés
je trouve pas pour le moment
on va faire d'am dam à 3 cd choper ça là
bas
mariage suis en train de trop réfléchir
j'ai trop pris de temps j'ai voulu
chercher un truc qui marchait mais il
n'y avait rien
et du coup j'ai perdu trop de temps ce
qui était ridicule ouais mais c'est le
beau jeu après un
qu'elle aille à damien et c'est fini il
ya dame prend un f2 et dans prend il n'a
pas vu mais j'ai plus assez de temps à
même s'il a plus d' échec et que j'ai du
tour b 8 qui arrivera c'est dommage
qu'on ait autant réfléchi ce qu'on
revient à fond là il s'est raté on
revient à fond mais on va pas y arriver
dommage dommage
à
on vient mourir à 0,26 quel dommage à
0,6 quel dommage
pas de chance
on va écrire c'est en fait je me rends
compte que notre truc et pai pas ouvert
sur trace tv ce qui devrait être le cas
e
attendez je vais faire ce chasse french
weekly stream
ok prisse prison va prendre comme ça à
l'aller un parti si demain je n'étais
pas loin quoi
alors ça c'est toujours de son plus con
qu'il ya dame là bas qui est chiant à la
ccip chiant ça
que vous avez compris le concept s'est
joué des poubelles tout temps partout
mais ça peut être un peu chaud donc là
ce que j'ai essayé de faire c'est d'être
mort en recettes
vous allez voir georges évite les dames
h7 et compagnie et surprise prise damage
sage faire cavaler f6 d'un match 8 et
chaque province est serein on va pouvoir
faire qui a valu à petit ce qui est cool
parce que ça me permet de couvrir la
case h7 avec l'idée de faire vite des
six bouger rockets madame e set
assez chiant [ __ ]
de nouveau une poubelle non truc c'est
que tu en fait le seul grand big five
pas de gambie avec les noirs avec les
blancs non plus d'ailleurs mais un homme
qui est peut-être le blackmar ça peut
aller mais le truc avec gecas très
mauvais ça ce très mauvais bon là on
n'est pas désespérée non plus un de leur
prendre à faire le grand roque il ya
cavalli ou quatre qui est hyper pénible
je joue mal est-ce que ça c'est si grave
genre qui a et b 5 à 6 mais après je
remets de foncer 8 au cas où
et je défends mais j'ai rapidement pour
rien encore dans les arénas je serais
tellement de deux poubelles
mais c'est de se recycler et du col un
petit dame jessains car on est de le
piéger - on joue pour des pièges et ans
et 5 20% qu'il n'est pas si mal
faut que je fasse gaffe je me barre avec
la dame je peux avoir des vrais soucis à
base de cavalli b5 il falloir que je
contrôle sa jordan f6 qui a et b 5 c'est
pénible je pense on va commencer par b6
du coup même si j'aime pas du tout
j'essaye de créer le l'incertitude
lâchement jeune assassin puisqu'il a
plus de casse pour la dame sur la
quatrième je faire à cinq quand même bon
là il fut la protégée de pions mais
c'est pas grave car ne pas me faire
piéger mais l'absence est en train de
devenir comme c'est en train de devenir
chiant pour les blancs ok il a reculé
mais il commence il se fait déjà au
tapis un pion il ya ça en prise à sa
emprise en récit se fait raser ces trois
pions à la droite c'est fantastique
du coup deux pions de plus je peux
passer à deux pions deux mois et même
pire en fait parce que là il se fait
raser
marquer l'intérêt de jouer ça en fait
surtout réduite qui pourrait paraître
piégeurs iliad amer de l'échec vêtements
et surtout recettes bayard prise là et
tour 17 à la faux pas
faut pas être très long pour gagner ça a
quand même un ok bon larrazet on le
rejoint bâle ont fait une grotte
alors là faut faire h4 absolument très
important sa cave a lieu sept cavaliers
la mettre le fou en g2 dans le fion
kétou une belle position 3 en bloc le
fou passage ou bien l'excellent
développement de la part des blancs
évidemment se place comme largement au
dessus de lui
flash cinq voix bien bloqué bon allez
maintenant développer un peu les pièces
halal dame
voilà comment on va pouvoir aller
rockets
on a réussi à roque est déjà très bien
henri pions h 6 il est temps de prendre
de l'espace à fond on va faire g5 on va
se value affaiblir la grande diagonale
voilà c'est cool on va prendre
j'aime être ce qui a régné en f3 comme
ça j'ai des cavaliers qui se tiennent et
il peut y avoir des réseaux qui peuvent
se créer bon j'ai raté ça
aïe aïe aïe je vais rater ça toute ma
grob
qui s'écroule mais bon
on veut faire un 4 essais du place un
dame c4 dans le bon tempo
on n'est pas encore fini les mecs la
grotte n'est jamais morte va faire 4
quand même je veux pas le laisser faire
des trois dans de bonnes conditions
qui sait peut-être que
champion prend
c'est une horreur qu ali prend à 2,3 b1
et c'est une horreur
si on prend ces deux ça atroce mais bon
chez objets jouets pour ça parce que je
joue pour dames 6 je suis j'ai joué pour
ça désolé damas cinq échecs roye b 1
mais je joue pour dames 6 et c'est
peut-être pas si simple à éviter parce
que j'ai tout contrôlé là c'est david
copperfield
enfin
on attend tf6 f7 on a quoi demander une
tour de moins c'est rien ça qu'on va
prendre la main et ça fonctionne pas du
tout
pagé rater ça je vois rien quelle
horreur on est quand même très mal
à
avoir du mal à mater un trajet tout
laisser tomber
j'ai tenté du beau jeu à fond mais j'ai
pas si j'aurais pu faire mieux
on était si mal que ça a tenté de touche
assez mais l'apd est truquée pro f 7 est
un truc et cavaliers e6 et tous mes week
et bekaert échec qui arrivait dans mon
été philippe façon ont été faits comme
des rats
bon c'était marrant allez on va chercher
un nouvel adversaire
on n'a pas des adversaires très amusant
ce soir je dois dire je dois dire qu'on
n'a pas les adversaires les plus
amusants du monde
même jour à kiev 5 je déteste jouer
comme ça avec les blancs je sais pas ce
que je fais c'est ridicule ce que je
suis en train de faire je sens que c'est
super mauvaises que je n'ai même pas
réfléchi en fait
non mais c'est honteux
fr kg cinq échecs c'est pas mal ça du
coup sûr pions pranger dame prend h5
dame pranger dame g6 et sur x h si je
fais les français s'ils se reprendre de
l'autre côté du coup et je joue sur ce
clou âge
allez bon et là du coup bah je vais
prendre là en fait
ça a l'air sympa tosh du coup on va
commencer un essai du fougueux 4 du tour
prend g5 qui peut arriver à tout moment
il ya le pion là qui peut rester en
prise ça m'a l'air cool mais je pensais
qu'ils allaient faire ces dames c'est 7
mai il tente quelque chose
ok c'est pas con genre si je fais tour
ici roi g 8 g pas d'âme j'ai six échecs
et sur dame prend ainsi si adam d un roi
g2a fff machin maths mais du coup je
peux peut-être commencer par tout
reprend ses 8 et l'idée c'est que
surtout reprend j'ai toujours cet échec
suroît h 8 g dames prend 1,6 et suroît
g8 j'aurais dame f7 rémy là encore rage
suite
ok mais g dames f6 3g et six dames 6 3 h
8 et dame prend ses huit matches c'est
joli ça t'en prends ces huit sites et
beaux dunks et qui auraient trouvé tout
reprend ses huit dans le chat qui aurait
trouvé la tactique parce qu'elle était
jolie cela et sur wii fit yade à metz
est mat parce que ça c'était joli pour
la peine tu pas est ce que vous en
pensez dans le tchat
on va laisser le chat on peut réagir à
cette tactique parce que c'est joli mais
qui qui aurait déjà vu que tours 7
roy g8 c'était de la merde d'un proche
six dames d un rejet de f3 match qui
aurait vu ça parce qu'il faut savoir un
peu quel est votre niveau dans le chatt
puisque ça c'est quand même la base si
vous voulez bien jouer aux échecs ses
devoirs des tactiques comme ça c'est un
peu des tactiques à la con con c'est
important quoi mais du coup tout pensé
mais tu penses était bien joué mais
personne n'aurait vu ça vous paraît
vraiment compliqué de voir tout ça
séparé mais je sais que ça vous paraît
compliqué selon ces trucs là mais c'est
vraiment important
enfin je dis pas ça pour faire chier
mais un peu quand même tu vois pas ce
que je suis un peu chiant mais mais
c'est important de voir cette tactique
là
en longue vous auriez vu que moquer mais
je vous assure que c'est en très
mauvaise formule en plus je joue pas
très bien ce soir je vois pas très bien
mais ok c'est important c'est vraiment
important ce genre de tactique
évidemment prépare bay 5-1 pis boom 5
moment vos atouts qu'on donne tout
on va faire un petit on va faire un bide
comme ça alors là tout envoyer et après
on réfléchira on va prendre ici je pense
qu'on est bien là je pense qu'on est
beaucoup mieux
ouais je perde le pion des 5 et où c'est
la méthode coué quoi
j'ai eu les c je vais reprendre 2g et
puis en fait ce fou de cases blanches
façon dans les françaises ça ça y sert à
rien on va partir dans la du principe
qu'on vous l'équivalent d'une française
mais on va mettre nos pions sur mettre
tous nos pions sur blanc
j'ai quasiment il le reprend de des
émeus créé un genre de thé comme dans
tetris
ça ressemble salao trucs un peu bizarres
dans tetris le cicc tout tout tout tout
tout tout tout tout tout tout tout tout
tout tout ta ta ta ta ta ta nana na na
na na peut-être des fans de tetris si
chez dams et quatre têtes un cap qui est
chiant
tu as perdu dame ces sept on s'en prend
un peu à lui
bon c'est pas du tour c'est 8 on va s'en
prendre à lui et cif et ours et en fera
fou prend 1,5 à et surtout prend 1,5
dame de france est un
il me matrat hockey où il ne fait pas il
a du coup si je fais dame ces deux
prises prise éventuellement peu
l'emmerdé
j'aimerais bien pouvoir bloquer ception
et pas les laisser avancer
bon alors à jouer risques et on va
prendre la couronne c
on va aller on va aller on va les
prendre la colonie on va essayer d'aller
mater à la barbare là parce que j'ai
peur que sinon de toute façon on perde
je vais prendre la presse on s'y fait b
si je prends un intermédiaire il a pas
le temps de prendre ses sept
et à tour c'est celle qui est super
chiant
donc j'aurais fait tourner ses scènes
pour chasser la dame cette diagonale ça
me paraît super dangereuse qu'il est en
train de faire est assez naïf ce que
zurich / g 3 juin lors d'un f3 et je me
lasserai prison eux en f2 pour gagner la
dame donc genre il n'a pas le temps de
faire food et 4 il peut faire dams et de
encore mais je prends il prend et je
fais fouet trois quand même ok je fais
fouet trois quand même et je menace
d'amitié échec
tout tout tout tout tout tout tout tout
tout tout tout tout tout tintin tintin
tu te fais maths et mais du coup on fait
du tetris en reste vous prend à cette
aussi des re mais enfin ils étaient
super naïf enfin ce que j'ai fait
c'était complètement du cac à quoi mais
complètement las il fait juste pour ses
7 ans premier madame est chassée de la
grande diagonale j'ai plus rien quoi je
sais pas ce que je fais j'abandonne
dommage pas de chance pas de chance pas
de chance
pas de chance voilà on continue avec
queen c'est quick wins out in j'espère
que je pourrai voir tous toutes ces
choses aussi vite que toi quoi je
comprends moi aussi ah ouais merde moi
jouer aussi vite
alors peut-être qu'ils le jouent mieux
ce gang y que moi je le joue en fait
voir faut que j'étudie ce gambie table
et à peut-être dame ici qui est pas mal
ah ouais ouais c'est pas qu'on l'ait ce
qui est en train de faire pas j'en sais
rien j'ai complètement perdu dans ses
gants dit je pense que joue super mal en
fait il faut que faut que les étudiants
ça me paraît quand même super violence
qu il en train de faire
je vais faire donne des 5 g pour
objectif d'essayer de faire en prison ni
prénom mais ça jamais marcher ça jusqu'à
si je prends prend fou à 6,3 17 tours
besset 3,8
ça marchera jamais dans mon affaire
d'âme des 5 et façon il ya des français
6 pour le pouvoir
qu'est-ce que je suis con [ __ ]
comment est ce que je peux essayer de
maths et de ses à la brutale quoi
inventé ça comme ça
je suis allée brutalisé bouffe à bouffer
le matériel vas-y manche c'est bon quoi
bon ok on peut pas on peut pas se
permettre d'échanger les dames cantons
et des bruits de pure et dure de toute
façon c'est un même à rien d'y penser
avec colin petit échec en premier
toujours floues b 5 1 pour 1
très décevant 7e position
vous avez voulu faire du beau jeu j'ai
pas réussi
déplorable c'est très mal joué je mérite
vraiment pas de gagner salement
j'ai tenté du beau jeu j'ai tenté du
beau jeu j'ai tenté du beau jeu mais tu
peux trouve même mal parce que je me
réactifs par la fnaim activer un je suis
pas du tout acte iv je fais que de la
merde
on est je mérite complètement de perdre
encore abandonné j'ai pas réussi à mater
je vais faire un joli match j'ai voulu
faire le beau jesus pas réussi désolé
excusez moi n'importe quoi d'être signé
bah c'est le problème du beau jeu 1 a
été plus dans l'esprit que moi était
plus dans l'esprit que moi elle ne veut
pas prendre les pions
j'aurais pas dû faire g6 qu'un mois les
je prends au bout d'un moment
tombé sur sur plus con que moi à la
partie d'avant ça c'est théorique je
passe t'il mecs emilie la transférer
dans une attaque pas neuf
je sais pas s'il est vraiment courant de
ce qui fait est il au courant de ce
qu'il fait
je commençais par cinq mais là j'ai eu
un coup de mou les mecs s'alléger un
coup de fatigue
ouf j'ai commencé ce matin à 8h30 place
d'un stop et le coup là ça y est l'ag je
sens largement le coup de mou mais
monumental
une impression de vide dans le cerveau
la hallucinant tout dans le coup comme
ça sans prévenir quoi
voilà le truc qui te dit mme en pls
total d'un comme ça d'un seul coup
vraiment
on est complètement foutu mais voilà
c'est ça peut-être revenir un petit
second souffle à mais l'impression d'un
mal de tête l' hyper violent d'un seul
coup ils sont là en prise à toute
emprise est complètement foutu
allez faut résister
faut résister
j'allais m'en fous ici
c'est un jour si la dame partout alors
évidemment d'emprunt f2
mais je veux faire juste pour ces huit
prises
je vous tends peu madame pour colmater 1
avantage ou beaucoup plus vite que lui
j'ai attaqué quand même je suis très
heureux si je me débarrasse de ce pion
il va revenir en b3 à apprendre de
l'espace ange pas de pain sur les
anglais trois potes perdant très vite
je suis complètement foutu
fait chier [ __ ] j'ai super mal joué
fowler a marqué
tassin paraît compliquer arnaquer
aïe aïe aïe on perd contre avec super
nul bon on l'a battu dans les arénas à
chaque fois donc il vaut mieux perdre
contre lui maintenant que de perdre
contre lui un autre moment c'était le
bon moment pour perdre entre guillemets
mais bon au final on voit que même sans
jouer d'ouverture tout ça on s'en dit
cap pas trop hein dire par là que pas
avoir d'ouverture c'est pas un énorme
handicap vous pouvez vraiment faire de
la merde des autres qui prend des cinq
qui va fonctionner vous pouvez vraiment
joué de la mère d'avoir des bons
résultats c'est pas à ce pas une excuse
un des mecs si vous dites que ouais
j'sais pas d'ouverture tous avons comme
moi si vous gueulez tout le temps
franchement ce pas une excuse que vous
auriez vraiment jusqu'à 2500 vraiment
que de la merde c'est possible hier je
viens de le prouver
je viens de le prouver
j'obtiens rien du tout
d'ailleurs à partir de la semaine
prochaine il va y avoir des tournois
pour un club de chasse comme france sur
czech comme donc vous inscrire ce sera
tous les vendredis car il réduit un
guide swingner loup non plus j'ai pas
d'ouverture donc jusqu'à 2003 en longues
tu peux aussi battu à lens 2 2 bon c'est
pas trop mauvais cap leucate ça va aller
on va les 120 on va on va se diriger
vers g5 s'est pas trop mal non plus moi
je vais jusqu'à 21h30 encore 10 minutes
si vous avez des questions n'hésitez pas
dans les tchats respectifs chachachas
comme chat on a quand même envoyé du
lourd
alors
bon allez jambes me le prendre on verra
bien franchement j'ai la flemme de 4q là
c'est fini
j'ai plus long envie de calculer sur la
je suis en roue libre
la queen the queens narita qui m'a dit
kiev j'ai beaucoup aimé ta nul contre
magnus avec la grande boum la grande on
va essayer de faire du fou prend 1,7 kg
cinq dames pranger 4 fait même si ces
dames c'est ça je vais le tenter enfin
peut-être du damage saint caprais
alliaura cavaliers l6 le retour on peut
pas bon bah si on peut pas on va faire
un cahier b3 savoir viser la casse des
cats on menace toujours un du fou trois
sets car lg 5 dames frange des quatre
ils l'empêchent bon c'est chiant il ya
cavalia 4 qui va arriver il ya le chat
qui est la fonte va faire tes idées de
on va revenir va revenir colmater tout
ça voilà ça joue très mal très mauvaise
partie la chanson on a versé à juste
plus nul que moi ce conquérir quatre
comme tu fais tu aimes pouvoir enfin
perso je réfléchirai pas 10 mais on va
faire cavalier de fieux quasi envie de
près move qui aura lieu 4 elle s'appelle
région s'étant abattue joue quand même
fréquent scandinave cela système de
l'ong one mais bon c'est ya rien à
apprendre
je pense si vous bossez je sais pas moi
une centaine d'heures vous pouvez avoir
mon répertoire
et quand même ridiculement peu on le
fait tomber un comme une comme des
mondes
je tenais à la dame allez vous prend la
dame mais bon tu n'as plus de temps
fallait jouer plus vite mais bon tu
joues pas vite tu joues pas habitat
alors on essaye de tout près mou mais
c'est déjà sur une partie foule près
move
une partie foot près mouche allez on
premise tout le temps on ne fait que ça
enfin quasi quoi tu adores il peut faire
re 5 mais voilà sinon sous le pré vous
ont quasi foule près move
et on supprime on n'a pas le droit de
réfléchir interdite on est très mal mais
bon ouverture écrira t on restera la
prochaine de le battre en fout près move
pas le droit de réfléchir seul temps
qu'on perd ses mémoires on va on va on
va se faire défoncer on va retenter avec
une meilleure ouverture là quand même
des quatre des cinq ans auprès move
c'est un petit match donc on joue un
truc plus normal on est complètement
foutu on va leur tente et
on peut abandonner
ce sens on a perdu notre challenge on va
réfléchir
voilà on retente à la prochaine dernière
partie on retente le foot prémices d'un
chien fou primove là
je vais faire des cinq là c'est pas bon
prendre de la dame prend la prom' de la
dame
attendu du caleçon le pré vous allez
mettre la dame ont eu quatre
j'ai plus assez la forme pour le réussir
ce challenge du cavaliere 4 et truc qui
arrive
j'ai plus assez le peps faut le faire en
début de ce tri le full près vous n'avez
qu'à l'étranger de il y en a de partout
mec joue pas mal en plus pas forcément
le meilleur adversaire faire un fou de
près move
ah ouais non et trop mal j'y arriverais
pas une autre fois peut-être notre dame
prend un f4
un truc c'est qu'il réfléchit et qui
jouent des bons coups c'est un problème
je vais battu à l'aller 1 fois mais pas
en stream ans
non encore que je me remet à rêver
c'est pas tout à fait prêt move près
mouvement joue très vite je voulais
faire kg 5 tempo juste et missclick mais
comme dans l'esprit j'étais en prêt mou
j'espère que j'ai pas rater un match
mais je tiens ça je tiens ça sur dame a
changé tour g1
ouais je suis peut-être pas si mal non
mais je souhaite m'en raide mais géré
par la ce a peut-être se tenir à wemmel
achetant près move [ __ ] j'ai pas le
droit de réfléchir
bah je me fais maths et mais j'étais pas
en pré move c'était à trish je n'avais
pas le droit quoi je n'avais pas le
droit
là aussi j'ai réfléchi quoi c'est pas du
jeu
donc j'ai perdu le challenge évidemment
la victoire ne compte pas ici
quel dommage quel dommage que j'étais
pas loin de le jeter pas loin de là
gagner
j'étais pas loin de là gagner mais ça
compte pas 50 par malheureusement trop
trop trop 8 to slow quoi j'ai été trop
lents
dommage dommage puisque ans avec un peu
plus de vitesse je le je le battais en
promouvant tous les coups bas sur ce les
mecs j'espère que vous avez que vous
avez qui fait les mecs je l'avais un
parti c'était un petit challenge fun
j'ai été un poil lent mais mais bon sur
ce on se retrouve lundi pour la
prochaine arena bien évidemment la
royale sur la chaîne dite stream
on se retrouve jeudi prochain pour le
tournoi mensuel et aussi donc à partir
de vendredi prochain lors des tournois
hebdomadaires sur votre chaise comme les
vendredis à 20h toi français donc
je vous tiendrai au courant bonne soirée
à tous et à bientôt
tiens les mecs